i only have one shot
is he here
is jen here
i don't see him
it's a little nerve-wracking right now
it feels like a calm before the storm
a storm being
jammed
so i'm new to the corridor office i'm
new to the corridor crew i mean i'm just
an intern but i keep seeing all these
different rituals uh this thing uh
see a lot of that
there's a smash breaks you know there's
a lot of things that go on but the one
that stands out above all else is
anytime jan comes in the office there's
pandemonium jan has this game that he
always plays with us where every time
jan comes by he tries to kill us all
with these nerf guns and so we are
forced to like defend ourselves
[Music]
it's literally an ongoing war we've had
for like 10 years now and so it just
feels wrong just because we're more
adult now to get rid of it jan's better
with the nerf blaster so every time i've
gotten in uh a blast off with him he
always manages to get me before i can
get him so i decided to uh go the way of
the blade this time last time you saw
jan he had just received a new peaky
finger well he's made some upgrades of
his own and he's coming by to show us
today and for us to begin working on
some new arrangements for his finger but
first as always
jan should be here any minute we don't
know where he's coming in
i'm a non-combatant for now
for now
you see that round oh my god that one
right there that has your name on it all
right
scared me man
i scared you you scared me
oh
i literally haven't seen any of it but i
hear screaming bang bang oh yeah you
know and
it sounds fun
i'm outta
here oh that doesn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i missed
one shot
he killed everyone
[Music]
i got my arm perfect yes
gg gg i was so close to a teamwork
so close that was close but it wasn't
quite enough so jan last time people saw
you was two years ago and in that time
people have been asking me do you still
even wear the finger
oh wow
oh man oh man
this be they i basically have every
color in the rainbow i don't even know
how to describe what i'm looking at
right here you've made so many which one
is the original right there this is this
is the original one it's still got the
janky layer shift and everything it's
your personal signature my personal
signature is jank
you actually got into 3d printing
because you wanted new fingers and now
you have a bunch of different versions
you can match to any outfit you could
potentially ever have you opened the
door into an evolved life i am now
more than man
and more than a machine
made me a god
and of course i use the fingers in fact
i use them pretty much every day the
only time i really take them off is rock
climbing
oh thank you bro i mean
oh
dude that was special
uh don't worry landed on the rock
okay we can get it back we can get back
good good good good and i had a finger
printed
out of
stainless steel
this one though
really has a gratifying
it's cool
it's the roll royce oh yes it's got like
actual like mass yeah but jan you are
here today for a very specific reason
you are at a restaurant and you saw nico
sitting unarmed and you wanted to shoot
him with a nerf gun because that's the
game we play there i am confronted face
to face with a combatant
and i'm unprepared
[Music]
and i would like to never repeat that
mistake i would like to live the rest of
my life
knowing i am better i think it's time to
remedy your pain i want to make sure
that you are perfectly armed with the
correct weapon to assassinate anyone
when they're not ready by turning your
finger into a nerf blaster you're
looking to give me an upgrade peaky
promise
i will make you a nerf finger the first
thing we need to do is figure out what
exactly you want so we can orient our
goals around that regardless of how it
actually shoots it what do you want an
inner finger when i close my eyes i
picture an elegant design something that
wouldn't weigh me down something that
wouldn't get in the way it's much like
this finger in that it's just a finger
so that eliminates any of the ideas we
have about like having a tube running
down to your back and having like a
whole like pneumatic actuator or power
system on your belt and look if that's
the reality of the situation brad that's
even more cyberpunk because that's
something we could do where we have it
built into like your wrist strap here
this section of it would be the
nerf blaster the string kind of coming
through wrap over here and then go down
as you
pull on this this will rotate and then
on the end over here we have the actual
nerf
tip
uh
let me redraw this
i heard jan and ren talking i thought
hey there's something i can help out
with because i don't know visual effects
very well um i've been here for a while
and i haven't really learned a lot but i
did go to engineering school ren and jan
had a bunch of ideas going into this
this shell that maybe comes up and
around but this is also on a hinge
which is fine because ideas are good but
a lot of them were very complicated what
if you pulled your finger back like this
and it actually shot outwards that way
okay some of them are very nonsensical
i'm not hesitating to say that some sort
of twist crank and you have that on the
ring on your other hand so you can be
like
yeah
okay that's pretty sweet that's great we
got to come up with a whole bunch of
ideas so i need mark's help to come up
with a propulsion system for this nerf
blaster so i went to the drawing board
and i started doing research how do you
propel an object is really the
fundamental basis of this because once
you know how then you can know how small
you can make it you have a gas
propellant you have gun powder you have
some kind of explosive propellant you
have springs you have pneumatics
technically you could make a rail gun
and have magnetic propulsion which would
be very cool but all these are very
complicated and many of them have
multiple points of failure and that's
the biggest problem with engineering is
when you have too many points of failure
so you try to minimize the number of
places where it can go wrong
the most reliable solution will be the
one that you actually want on the
battlefield
uh this is a co2 nerf gun made by wreck
attack i'm really happy i found
oh man dude look what i found oh that
was sitting in this box how did you not
get the box too i think we need to test
these out just to even see if co2 is
viable for this project
[Music]
i think this is armed now i don't want
to fire this at anyone until i know how
hard this fires
it's way too tight in here let's let's
go shoot it out there
oh my god
what
try to shoot the couch
oh my god
oh my wait
wait
wait
oh
no
you're crazy don't worry the intern will
clean it up
okay that glass went everywhere you guys
got broom
oh thank you
there you go
okay i'm gonna shoot you in the back
three two one
ow
that just graced me in that hurt you
okay i'm good i'm good we can't give him
800 psi hit me
that that hurt about as bad as like an
airsoft bb
[Music]
oh
no safety safety anybody's safety it's a
check check safety anybody's safety
oh i always want people to be safe when
they're getting hurt
what the heck
so that's a lot of pressure mark has
gone ahead and literally taken apart an
old airsoft gun and so this is the
simplest mechanism so here's the air
container here's the co2 cartridge it
literally slots in like this using an
allen key we tighten it and then that
will release all the air pressure into
the actual valve here and the idea is
that just simply pressing this release
will let air out
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa dude much pressure no this is
perfect you want someone to be hit with
that oh it broke it there was so much
air pressure in it it literally split
the dart apart
hence the whole concern of 800 pounds
per square inch uh i like it
you're the one that's going to be shot
by it yeah true oh my god you're right i
didn't think about that
okay we are now taking a break from
shooting season two of son of a dungeon
so that i can tell you about our sponsor
audible because i've been listening to
this really cool book called the
calculating stars from the lady
astronaut series by marie robinette
cowell so picture it's 1950s space race
era except
a giant asteroid takes out pretty much
all of the eastern seaboard and has now
put enough moisture into the atmosphere
that in 50 years the climate will be
uninhabitable so instead of a space race
fueled by the cold war we have a space
race fueled by survival if you're into
space stuff or engineering and math
stuff like that this book is awesome and
of course you can listen to this book on
audible of course audible's got the
largest library of audiobooks but if
audiobooks aren't quite your thing
they've got podcasts too tons of
podcasts you got thousands of titles
that you can listen to you got some from
the premium membership that you can
listen to for free but also with your
membership every month you get a free
credit that you can spend on any book
regardless of its price it's a great
deal and the best part you can download
them all to your device or stream them
directly from the internet whichever
one's more convenient or better for you
if this title sounds interesting to you
check it out by going to the link in the
description or just go to audible.com
corridor crew and guess what you can
even text corridor crew to 500 500 and
you will get a free 30-day trial thanks
again to audible and back to the video
so even though the co2 cartridges are
very nice and powerful i think mark is
right with wren's incredible guidance
and his genius shining down upon me what
i've been blessed with wisdom
airsoft literally has electronically
controlled valves to regulate air
pressure that is the whole fundamental
basis of it how is this different than
the thing that we're messing around with
downstairs though was that not an
airsoft thing
that that's the thing it was exactly but
that's not electronically controlled
that is mechanically controlled it needs
to cut to one
oh this is more reliable you can have a
button press these kits exactly are what
we're talking about they're wired up
they have a controller all we do is hook
it up through a high pressure tube to
the barrel and then at the press of a
button
i've yet to meet jam you haven't met
james i've never met jan dude
you're not missing out okay
so i don't know anything about these
sort of airsoft pistols and whatnot but
evic they are located here in la they're
nearby actually we could go directly
there and
have them answer all of our questions
perhaps are we in the section oh we're
here we're here
oh this is it we're here
evic pointed us in a direction that i
didn't even know existed your motor your
piston
all of that is held up here
this seems to me to be a much easier way
to slap on somebody's wrist than an
entire air setup this is an airsoft
pistol but this is not a normal co2 air
pistol this is a
motorized pistol it is entirely battery
powered there is no co2 what this does
is a very clever compact mechanism where
the battery powers a motor in the bottom
to pull back a miniaturized piston
that's in the grip in the same way that
this pulls back
this motor in the bottom of here spins
to pull back a piston and that creates a
pocket of air the air is primed in the
chamber and it pushes the bb
air
this is a compact solution that delivers
reliable air through battery power for
me this is what i really believe is the
best solution i think it's going to be
worth it so i got to rip this apart i'm
hoping that matt can take the actual
build to the finish line mark handed me
an auto electric pistol that had its own
self-contained piston system and asked
me to make it capable of connecting to a
finger the biggest factor in all of this
is trying to maintain a seal and trying
to like reduce as much complexity as you
possibly can to get that air into the
dart and nowhere else so we slide the
dart into here and then the tube
supplies air straight into the dart we
used resin printing this time around the
build resin effectively is a very very
strong version of what normal resin is
and it allowed us to have very very
small parts that actually allowed us to
have like a lot of precision in a very
very small package
i think i've gotten to our prototype i
put the piston inside of this leather
pouch that i created and then made a
little wrap around for it and then i
directly attached the piston to this
rubber hose that comes down to this
finger linkage
then i ran leads out of the auto
electric pistol to a sound button for
now
we can change that to be whatever the
sweet button obviously is too big we'll
need a different one but
i think the other thing that it probably
needs is some elegant way to hide the
cables as they're coming up you're
suggesting having some sort of actual
like glove because then that way you can
have the actual power wires going up
following up the hose and then maybe
divert around the knuckles here inside
of the the clothing that's what you're
suggesting when he slips on it's like a
nintendo power glove you know in a way
either the bracer slaps on here and
slaps on here velcro velcro or if you
just slap on slide over wrist velcro
here or it's all one slide-on piece so
now that i have the trigger the battery
and the motor all connected i have to
build a gauntlet that jan can wear that
holds all the components in one place so
i decided to make it out of leather bust
out that sewing machine creation is the
fun part and if creation under dire
straights is what it is it's like even
the challenge is good i'm gonna go ahead
and detach this i don't have a knife
yeah scissors okay
that's on corridor digital.com we have
even more like details as to how this
thing went together
i made a ring it is as simple as this
you just you just need a big button it's
a very very analog kind of thing and it
allows him to activate it at the push of
a button which is conveniently right on
his finger
i don't know how well the string is
gonna work but we at least got a
ligament in there now so something that
should be able to actually make it
function as a finger so
as opposed to just like a floppy digit
it's there it's
this is for the left hand right
what right hand
it's just
oh no
is he missing his left left finger i'm
pretty sure
let me let me just double check this
we've always done it gesticulating i'm
hoping it's his right hand right now
we've always done that we've been uh
boom boom boom
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no no don't panic
my fellow corridor crewmates
this is fixable for you see
hands
rotate burner
we just have to thread it
the other way around
i'm unprepared
i came
here today with the intent to do a team
wipe and not stop me and then the
secondary objective of perhaps getting a
nerf
finger
so how's that going guys we have
something
can't wait can't wait through it all we
persisted because we knew the end goal
of arming you to make you the most
dangerous nerf player in the world was
achievable
thrilled to enter the upper echelon i'm
thrilled to become an s-class player i
want to present to you version 12 of the
nerf finger
[Music]
hold on what you have here is a 25-watt
motor spinning at 5000 rpm housed in a
composite aluminum plastic container
with a 30 to 1 gear ratio pulling a 12
centimeter pin that's going to fire 300
cubic centimeters of air straight
through this tube into the custom-made
50 millimeter firing tube that's going
to be mounted to your finger
to your exact specifications capable of
firing a nerf dart
at over a hundred feet per second i
can't wait for this i could honestly see
myself wearing it for sure the the ring
is rad the
shape and design of it the overall build
is
impressive to say the very least what
will he destroy with the thing we have
created
our enemies
all of them
i just hope it works like my glove
he's ready he's lethal groovy
goodbye my friend
[Music]
good night
good night
good shot
[Laughter]
oh
the chaos i will inspire
be responsible never am i in the game
now
what is uh
you're in the game what is that what
does that mean from this point forward
mark
every time i see you and every time you
see me the game is on you went through
all of this to be brought into the game
[Laughter]
i may not have chosen this
and it may not have been what i thought
it was but i'll save the best for me now
and you my friend
[Applause]
that's what happens when you shake hands
with the nerve attachment
the look of joy
i felt like i was watching a child on
christmas or something i think it is
very cool i think it's rad the fact that
it even functions is a miracle in my
book
and the aesthetics on point and i don't
really have the feeling that it's going
to blow up and take my my arm
yeah oh it might that's a that's a
lithium polymer battery just charge it
yeah don't let it overheat it's kind of
black leather so it's not in the sun a
lot
good to know
[Applause]
not the face
how does it feel to be betrayed by your
own weapon
dubious i know
hey
dead
watch out
oh my god
oh so close
shadows i come out of get off our set